so you go to Miami for our basketball
you end up at any strip clubs at all
like do you do a level while you're out
there I love 11. I
um
yeah I love 11. they're like they're
like really good friends
I feel like you've been you've been
booked there before right yeah I've been
booked at 11 quite a few times I love 11
so much it's like my happy place I think
it is quite possibly the best club in
the world it's like top five top three
top two maybe one I'd say that because
it's like you get the best of it's like
a Vegas club with chicks exactly and
it's 24 hours yeah like you gotta be
like a mani I'm a maniac what's the
latest or the earliest in the morning
you've walked out of a club
the next day like 2 P.M
Jesus yeah 11.
how many hours wait wait how many hours
were you there
probably like 10
11 hours
what are you doing inside of 11 for that
long is there I mean are you eating are
you I mean obviously throwing money or
drinking Raging Raging yeah raging of
course that's a lot dancing raging
drinking dancing I've walked out of the
booby trap at around nine a.m yeah but
that's like to me that's manageable in
Miami like 2 p.m that's a lot that's
super degenerative I think we went there
at like 8 A.M okay that's fair so like 7
A.M I don't know if you were like yo I
performed at 2 30 and I stayed until two
no no no I pulled the whole 12-hour
shift in that [__] no no no I didn't
performance day it was like we were
outside and then we went to 11 for
breakfast ah
they got breakfast like omelets yeah
they got like these chicken waffles
that's fire chicken and waffles in the
morning if you go in the morning because
they're 24 hours so we had been out all
night and then we went to 11 and I think
we left at like 2 p.m
um
is it nice to have the barbs in your
corner
I feel like the barbs [__] with you and
that's a good place to be in and just in
the world yeah they've shown me so much
love and so much support like The Vibes
are like
like who needs a
uh like for Nikki it's like she doesn't
even need a label like sheeps are their
own
um like she just treated last night
because she didn't go to met Galen she
was like number one on trending Legend
it's crazy because the barbs came to my
defense because I said something about
uh I love Little Kim but I said
something that little Kim's whatever
they're called they're her barbs and
they came at me crazy for like two days
and then the barbs had my back they're
crazy it's just like a real army what is
do you have a fan base name
it's crazy
um I have titles and title with a couple
names but I think I'm gonna probably
just find one that comes naturally like
yeah yeah have you seen swarm on uh
Amazon Prime yet yes I did it's really
really crazy and it's also kind of like
scary like that it's kind of like not
too far from reality like and it's it's
a little crazy because
you don't really see women serial
killers so that was there was that one
movie uh
uh monster with Charlize Theron did you
ever watch that she was a serial killer
she was like a prostitute she used to
kill Truckers
yeah it was a good movie I'm gonna I
know Charlize Theron she's like really
beautiful girls yeah she like took on a
role as like this like white trash like
trucker lady who was like a lot lizard
do you know what a lot lizard is I don't
know what a lot lizard is
so it was a lot lizard
if you're a truck driver
they have truck stops and it's girls who
offer lonely men who are in trucks at
truck stops in the middle of nowhere
certain services so why they call them
lizards that's just what they call them
they call them a lot lizard that is
gross it is gross well it's a dirty name
like I I don't I don't disagree it's a
dirty name for a dirty job
um yo on this record uh you dropped 16
which I think is dope because you're
getting your [__] off on that oh thanks
give me some yo what so what job did you
get fired from
oh man I had like a a job at a like when
I was I had tons of jobs I had every
single job like grocery store bartending
waitressing but it was like a bartending
job I didn't oh yeah it was a bartending
job and you just told me to go [__] them
and Foot Locker too Footlocker yeah but
I had I have a great relationship with
Footlocker look I I I was like employee
of the year really no no no not really
but could could you like were you like
top tier assistant are you back door in
any of the shoes no I had keys and
everything I was super responsible like
good employee I was that girl yeah so
you weren't like if the pair of Jordans
came out no I wasn't stealing no no I'm
not saying stealing but you might set up
a parasite for you for the homie like
you know yeah I did that a few times
yeah yeah I used to do that for my
friends what was the last real job you
had was it the bartending thing yeah
and you just like did you literally tell
them [__] you when you when you got
fired no I didn't actually not that one
um
one of them yeah but not not the last
one so you could make a drink like you
could make like a yeah I'm actually like
I can make it I'm really a chef
what can you cook everything literally
everything when you say you're really a
chef what does that mean like the same
do you have like a certificate that says
so
are you just I'm a hood Chef you're a
hood Chef okay yes so what's like the
go-to if I had to be like okay Shelby
like what is your what are you gonna
make there you're very confident in
um well what do you like I'm I'm into
everything
I'm a fat [__] as we discussed like all
right I got some famous dishes of mine
like if you had to cook a dish for uh
give me the Gordon Ramsay dish he's
sitting there all right like I'm gonna
cook you something I would make it I
would make a medley of things okay
because I I feel as though if I have a
medley I can't lose if you don't like
one thing he's gonna like another thing
so I would do like these um lamb chops
that I do these garlic Char mint lamb
chops the mint okay they very like taste
level like
very high like it's not even regular at
all and then I would do a Chilean sea
bass
oh and then
I would do uh on another day if you come
I would do coconut curry chicken and
white rice Jesus that's a famous meal of
mine the people go crazy for you see
he's not in his head people go crazy the
people go absolutely insane and last but
not least lasagna rolls talk about it
that sounds fire
yo the best Italian food I ever had was
in Boston in Little Italy and there's
like those little bakeries that stay
open all night yeah oh my God cannolis
oh my goodness I miss the cannoli every
guy at the [__] club from DJ and [__]
face and everybody's a [__] Bakery
open at three in the morning like what
the [__] is going on over here
I love a bakery so lasagna rolls would
you ever okay because right now you know
there's just like all these rappers are
doing like an artist like uh Mr Beast
all these guys they're doing like a
ghost kitchens right yes so you could do
like b as bites oh you come on with the
ideas and then you could just license it
to a ghost kitchen and come up with
their own menu and then give them the
recipes and then you know people all
over the world can just but they'll have
then they'll have my recipes
I mean it could be like a watered down
version of the recipe like I feel like a
lasagna roll would be like like let me
get six of those like in a little box
yeah it's like that yeah yeah
you should do that you know what next
time I come I might bring a lasagna rose
that would be amazing yeah next time I
come here I'll bring lasagna rolls I'll
break my diet for that okay I'm on a
keto diet just because I like to brag
about how good it is and then people
then you can then you can vouch for me
so I don't have to do the talking next
time you'd be like you know who's a
really good Chef yeah